інклюзивний ресурсний центр самої зірки
починається інклюзивний свято для дітей
сусу брили мууу середньому по трубах самий
тут он і відривати психологу педагогічно
піт ринку для того, щоб мати ми жив і
весь піт і
даса дочка чашка ви тут яким вулицю
праві протягом
сухий мовчання київ малий по дорозі
прикладом доступності тарифних чоловіків
швидкі для всіх 8 нитку впав та ціни там
києві травня боти 47 таких і вказати на
ресурсних центрів алана шкода їх тільки
d'issey
повторюю 10 вона 47 відсів означає ще
сотні тисяч дітей диму ці чоловіки
влади нормально в шиї тис і я йду до
київради
a b c заміни ти чим шкірно дітей на
мало право на пу свиту чітко і вставши
європейську столицю
[музика]